Off.
Quand on regarde le ciel la nuit, l’univers
ne semble pas avoir de bord.
L’univers a l’air d’être de s’étendre
jusqu’à l’infini, et peut-être plus
loin encore.
Giordano Bruno adorait penser cela, fini est
une chose que son Dieu n’était pas.
Et de nos jours, beaucoup partagent ces réflexions,
qui dans le passé avaient défié la religion.
Mais certains trouvent l’hypothèse d’un
univers infini embêtante,
Et pour en savoir plus je vous conseille cette
vidéo de Science Étonnante.
Un tel univers possède une infinité de copies
de nous-mêmes,
Et moi… c’est peut-être juste moi…
mais moi, ça me pose problème…
Tout ça pour dire que je trouverais ça très
très fort,
S’il était possible de concevoir un univers
fini sans bord…
Off.
Ce fut du grand, très grand Henri Poincaré,
que vint une réflexion de toute beauté.
Alors que beaucoup pensaient qu’un univers
fini sans bord était un paradoxe,
Poincaré se mit à longuement contempler
une horloge.
Les aiguilles avancent indéfiniment dans
une seule et même direction
Pourtant, l’horloge est un objet tout à
fait fini.
Poincaré se rendit compte qu’un objet assez
banal méritait toute son attention.
Cet objet n’est pas l’aiguille de l’horloge
mais la trajectoire que cette aiguille décrit.
En termes mathématiques, ce dont on parle
est du cercle, et surtout de sa topologie.
Il s’agit de la seule forme géométrique
de dimension 1 à la fois sans bord et finie.
Plus précisément, Poincaré montra que tout
variété compacte de dimension 1 est obtenue,
À partir d’un cercle et d’une bijection
continue à réciproque continue…
Mais le cercle n’ayant qu’une dimension,
se pose alors la question de sa généralisation
!
Et bien, notre Terre est une sphère, dont
on peut dire qu’elle n’a aucune “vraie”
frontière.
Ou plutôt, quelque soit la direction de votre
chemin, vous pourrez marcher sans fin.
Elle est finalement plus surprenante qu’elle
en a l’air, notre belle planète Terre !
Mais la sphère n’est pas la seule surface,
à avoir autant de classe.
Comme on l’a vu quelques épisodes en arrière,
le monde de PACMAN a une propriété similaire.
Off.
Le monde de PACMAN est ce que l’on appelle
un tore, et l’on a vu qu’il n’avait
pas de bord.
De façon équivalente, le monde de PACMAN
peut être vu comme un carré,
Un carré dont on a collé les côtés opposés.
De sorte que quand PACMAN sort d’un côté,
Il réapparaît alors par le côté opposé.
On a donc maintenant deux surfaces finies
sans bord : la sphère et le tore.
Mais voilà qui pose une toute nouvelle sorte
de problème.
Comment être sûr que ces surfaces ne sont
pas les mêmes ?
Comment peut-on certifier que l’on ne pourra
jamais déformer continûment une surface,
Et obtenir tout à coup l’autre à la suite
d’un tour de passe-passe ?
Off.
Pour distinguer différentes surfaces en topologie,
Poincaré inventa l’homotopie.
Poincaré remarqua ainsi que les lacets sur
la sphère,
Pouvaient être sécoués, déformés puis
réduits à néant.
Et puis, surtout, Poincaré remarqua que ceci
pouvait se faire,
En déformant les lacets toujours continûment.
Cette remarque est valable pour la sphère,
j’espère qu’on en est d’accord.
En revanche, cette même remarque n’est
pas valable pour le tore,
Regardez par exemple le lacet dessiné à
l’écran.
Vous pouvez chercher à le déformer autant
que vous le voulez,
Ce lacet traversera toujours de gauche à
droite le carré.
Vous ne pourrez donc pas faire disparaître
ce lacet continûment.
On dit du tore qu’il n’est pas simplement
connexe.
On a en fait déjà vu un autre exemple similaire,
à savoir la topologie du cercle.
Le lacet qui en fait un tour complet,
Déformez-le autant que vous le voulez, jamais
il ne disparaît.
Après tout, toute déformation de ce lacet
devra faire un tour du cercle.
Et voilà comment on prouve que, comme le
tore, le cercle n’est pas simplement connexe.
Super ! On a bien avancé dans notre classification
des surfaces.
Mais notre espace, lui, est un espace à trois
dimensions.
Peut-on partir de la sphère et du tore et
en trouver des généralisations
Dont la topologie s’applique à notre véritable
espace ?
Off.
C’est à la fin du 19ème siècle, que Poincaré
généralisa tore, sphère et cercle.
En fait, Poincaré découvrit toute une collection
de topologies différentes
Que pouvait avoir un univers fini sans bord.
Dans cette vidéo, je vais me restreindre
uniquement,
À des généralisations de la sphère et
du tore.
Et je vais commencer par la généralisation
du second,
À un espace à trois dimensions.
Le tore 3D est en gros un cube dont on peut
traverser les faces.
Quand on sort par la droite, on réapparaît
à gauche.
Quand on sort par le haut, on réapparaît
en bas.
Et pour la direction avant arrière, il se
passe à peu près la même chose.
Comme vous l’auriez sans doute prédit,
le tore 3D est sans bord et fini.
De plus, tout comme sa version 2D et le cercle,
le tore 3D n’est pas simplement connexe.
Qu’en est-il de la généralisation de la
sphère ?
On va voir maintenant de quoi elle peut avoir
l’air.
Off.
Revenons-en d’abord à la sphère 2D qu’est
la surface de la Terre.
On a déjà vu que représenter cette sphère
n’est pas d’la tarte.
Le plus simple est sans doute d’utiliser
des cartes.
Ces cartes ne sont pas parfaites, mais elles
nous seront nécessaires.
Regardons surtout de plus près cette carte
centrée sur le pôle nord.
La surface entière de notre Terre y est représentée
par un disque,
Quoique…
il me faut tout de même mettre un gros astérisque.
Sur cette carte, le pôle sud se trouve étalé
tout le long du bord.
J’espère que vous avez bien tout ceci en
tête et au fond de votre coeur.
Parce qu’on s’apprête à transposer ces
propos à la dimension supérieure.
Par analogie, et vous allez voir ça va être
super cool,
Une sphère 3D, ou 3-sphère, peut être représentée
par l’intérieur d’une boule.
Disons, par exemple, par l’intérieur d’une
pomme.
Dont les pépins sont une sorte de pôle nord.
Mais, souvenez-vous, la vraie 3-sphère, elle,
n’a pas de bord.
La peau de la pomme représente en fait un
seul et unique atome.
Ou plutôt, elle représente un unique point
de la 3-sphère que l’on pourrait appeler
le pôle sud.
Mieux encore les points proches de la peau
Sont en fait juste à côté les uns des autres.
Je pense que vous commencez à en avoir l’habitude,
Mais toute personne qui sort d’un côté,
Peut littéralement choisir l’endroit sur
la peau où elle va réémerger.
Une dernière chose à dire sur la 3-sphère,
enfin,
Est que comme sa version 2D, elle possède
une connexité simple.
Super !
On vient de décrire deux espaces finis sans
bord,
À savoir le tore 3D et la 3-sphère.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’il peut y avoir d’autre
encore ?
Off.
Telle est la grande question que Poincaré
choisit de se poser,
Mais il sentait qu’il s’agissait d’une
question bien trop difficile.
Il opta alors pour une question plus facile,
Et il réussit à la résoudre dans le cas
de la 2D.
Il prouva que la sphère de dimension 2 était
la seule surface finie sans bord et simplement
connexe.
Mais le cas de la sphère de dimension 3 le
laissa perplexe.
Dans le dernier supplément d’un mémoire
qui allait tout changer,
Poincaré écrivit que cette question l’emmènerait
trop loin.
Cette question est ce que l’on appelle la
conjecture de Poincaré.
Et pendant plus d’un siècle, de réponse
il n’y en eut point.
Ce n’est qu’en 2003 que le russe Grigori
Perelman résolut la question.
Sa preuve était très longue et très subtile,
Et vérifier sa validité fut incroyablement
difficile.
Après près de 7 ans, ses pairs présentèrent
enfin leur conclusion.
Ils affirmèrent que la preuve de Perelman
était correcte.
Seule la 3-sphère est un espace fini, sans
bord et simplement connexe.
Pour sa preuve, Perelman reçut une floppée
de récompenses,
Y compris un pactole d’un million de dollars.
Cette somme peut paraître assez immense,
Mais Perelman était…
disons…
un peu bizarre.
Perelman refusa toutes ces décorations,
Et choisit de disparaître de la circulation.
Mais à n’en pas douter, il est l’auteur
d’un exploit époustouflant.
Non seulement a-t-il prouvé la fameuse conjecture
de Poincaré.
Il a aussi profondément avancé notre compréhension
des espaces 3D.
Et puis, enfin, il a montré qu’il était
l’un des plus grands géomètre de tous
les temps.